Вітаю друзі! Мене
звати Марія Растворова.
Я вчитель географії
Новопечерської школи.
Сьогодні ми продовжуємо з вами
вивчення курсу географії 11 класу
та вивчаємо тему «Українська держава».
Епіграфом до нашого уроку є
слова з Державного Гімну України:
"Душу й тіло ми положим за нашу свободу.
І покажем, що ми,
браття, козацького роду".
А тепер пропоную згадати те, що
ви вже знаєте з попередніх уроків.
Питання, які вивчались на попередніх
уроках, ви бачите на екрані.
Відповіли? Молодці! Рухаємося далі.
І також надам вам правильні відповіді
на питання для самоперевірки,
які були в попередньому уроці.
Питання та варіанти відповідей
на них ви бачите на екрані.
Правильна відповідь
на 1 і 2 питання - варіант В).
на 3 питання - варіант А).
Сподіваюся у всіх співпало.
Тепер пропоную згадати - які давні
народи заселяли територію України
та які державні утворення
існували на теренах нашої держави.
Нагадаю, що однією з перших
цивілізацій, яка сформувалася
на території України, була
трипільська цивілізація.
На цьому слайді ви можете побачити
як виглядало житло трипільців.
Трипільці були надзвичайно
розвинутою цивілізацією,
що мали свої технологічні
здобутки, а також одними із перших
на планеті почали будувати міста.
І досі зникнення трипільської
цивілізації є загадкою
для археологів та істориків.
Також територію сучасної
української держави свого часу
населяли такі войовничі
племена як скіфи,
які на згадку нам залишили
ось таку золоту пектораль,
що нині зберігається в Музеї
історичних коштовностей України
та розповідає нам про життя
скіфського суспільства.
І також про скіфів ще в
давні-давні часи писав Геродот.
На зміну скіфам прийшли
також войовничі племена,
які називалися сарматами.
На цьому барельєфі ви можете
побачити як вони виглядали.
Фундаментом Української
держави є Київська Русь.
Нагадую, що місто Київ, яке було
засновано Києм, Щеком і Хоривом
та їх сестрою Либідь, відповідно
до стародавньої легенди,
стало столицею тодішньої
Давньоруської держави.
І, зокрема, на слайді ви
можете побачити картину,
яка зображує Старокиївську гору із
якої, зокрема, і почався розвиток Києва.
Одним із факторів, що
сприяв економічному розвитку
Давньоруської держави, було
те, що її столиця місто Київ
знаходився на перетині
торгівельних шляхів.
Зокрема через місто Київ
проходив надзвичайно важливий
економічний та торгівельний
шлях «із варяг у греки»,
який сполучав Скандинавські
країни та Візантію.
І, зокрема, саме в київській гавані
купці зі Скандинавії та Візантії
зупинялися на відпочинок
та задля участі в ярмарках.
На цьому слайді ви можете
бачити надзвичайно відому картину
художника Івана Айвазовського, яка
зображує шлях «із варяг у греки»
та, зокрема, як судно
підходить до київської гавані.
Важливою віхою в історії розвитку
Київської Русі та державності України
було хрещення князем Володимиром
Київської Русі в 988 році.
Це сприяло об'єднанню племен та
їх консолідації в єдину державу.
І також на цьому слайді
ви можете побачити фреску
з Володимирського Собору, де
видатний художник Віктор Васнецов
зобразив як князь
Володимир хрестив киян.
Важливим етапом становлення
української держави була
козацька доба, зокрема перша Січ
була заснована в нижній течії Дніпра
Дмитром «Байдою» Вишневецьким.
Згодом Запорізька Січ розширила
свій геополітичний вплив із острова
на великі простори сучасних
українських земель та всієї Європи.
Зокрема козаки брали участь
у битві під Дюнкерком.
Згодом політична структура Запорізької
Січі та Гетьманської держави
відіграла дуже важливе
значення для подальшого
становлення державності України.
Надзвичайно суперечливим та
складним був період становлення
української державності
після революції 1917 року.
Цей період тривав два роки з 1917
по 1919 рік та характеризувався
постійною зміною державних
кордонів тодішньої України.
Зокрема в той час на території
сучасних українських земель
був сформований цілий ряд
державних утворень - зокрема,
Українська Народна Республіка та
Західноукраїнська Народна Республіка.
Відомими історичними постатями
того періоду зокрема були
Симон Петлюра, Михайло
Грушевський, гетьман Скоропадський
та Володимир Винниченко.
Втім потім, у зв'язку з історичними
процесами, українські землі
увійшли до складу
новоствореної радянської держави
як Українська Соціалістична
Радянська Республіка
і незалежність Україна
вже отримала в 1991 році,
коли Актом Незалежності
від 24 серпня 1991 року
було проголошено незалежність України.
Втім, проголошенню незалежності
України зокрема передував
живий ланцюг на День Соборності
в 1990 році, коли мешканці
багатьох сіл, міст і містечок
України утворили живий ланцюг
від західних до східних кордонів
нашої майбутньої незалежної держави,
тримаючи один одного за руки.
Державними символами України є прапор,
який складається із
блакитної та жовтої стрічки,
а також це Державний
Герб України, в основу якого ліг
тризуб князя Володимира.
Тепер пропоную дізнатися більше про риси
фізико-географічного
положення України.
Нагадаю, що територія
України повністю знаходиться
в північній і східній півкулі та
в помірному кліматичному поясі.
Площа нашої держави
складає 603,7 тисяч кв. км.
І нагадаю, що площа нашої держави
є, зокрема, більшою за площу
багатьох європейських держав,
таких як Німеччина, Франція, Італія,
Великобританія та інші держави.
Протяжність України із заходу
на схід складає 1316 км,
а протяжність України з півночі
на південь складає 889,6 км.
Отже, територія України займає
велику площу на карті Європи та світу.
І, зокрема, нагадаю вам
про крайні точки України.
Тепер пропоную дізнатися,
де ж знаходиться
географічний центр України.
Географічний центр України
розташований на північній околиці
села Мар'янівка, що належить
до Шполянського району
Черкаської області між районним
центром Шпола та селом Матусів.
Також ще виділяють
геометричний центр України,
який розташований у селі
Добровеличківка Кіровоградської області.
Також нагадаю, що Україна
знаходиться в центрі Європи,
зокрема про це свідчить
місцезнаходження тут
географічного центру Європи,
яким вважається село Ділове
Закарпатської області.
Втім, село Ділове є не єдиним
місцем, яке вважають центром Європи.
Також такі країни як Литва,
Польща та інші претендують
на місце розташування в
себе географічного центру.
І тепер пропоную дізнатися більше
про політико-географічне
положення України.
Нагадаю, що політико-географічне
положення держави -
це її положення щодо політичних
союзників і противників
та осередків політичних
конфліктів у світі.
Нагадаю, що ПГП є мінливим, тобто
воно може змінюватися в часі.
При оцінці політико-географічного
положення важливими
зокрема є: наявність виходу до
моря, контроль за комунікаціями,
характер відносин між сусідами,
форма території, кількість сусідів,
характер та інтенсивність
зв'язків із зовнішнім світом.
І тепер нагадаю, що
політико-географічне положення
характеризують на трьох рівнях:
глобальному, регіональному, сусідському.
Розпочнемо із характеристики глобального
політико-географічного
положення України.
Нагадаю, що глобальне
політико-географічне положення -
це геопросторове ставлення держави
до світової політичної системи
та її окремих підсистем, зокрема
до групи високорозвинених країн,
держав «третього» світу та
нинішніх постсоціалістичних країн,
та світових геополітичних
центрів сили тощо.
Яким чином можна
характеризувати геополітичне
політико-географічне положення України?
Воно є одночасно вигідним і складним.
Пропоную дізнатися чому.
Вигідність глобального
географічно-політичного положення
України зумовлена тим, що
територія нашої держави знаходиться
в досяжній відстані до важливих
стратегічних партнерів України,
зокрема до європейських держав.
Важливо зазначити, що Україна
є однією із держав-засновниць
Організації Об'єднаних
Націй і також Україна входить
до понад 80 неурядових
міжнародних організацій.
А ми з вами рухаємося
далі та дізнаємося більше
про пріоритети сучасної
зовнішньої політики України.
Одним із важливих пріоритетів
зовнішньої політики України
є, зокрема, розвиток
стратегічного партнерства
із Сполученими Штатами Америки.
Нагадаю, що Сполучені
Штати Америки належать
до «Великої сімки» і є
однією з найбільш економічно
та військово розвинених держав світу.
Також важливим є те, що
Сполучені Штати Америки
визнали агресію Російської
Федерації проти України
та підтримали Україну в цій боротьбі.
Також важливим пріоритетом
зовнішньої політики України
є розвиток курсу європейської
інтеграції та в подальшому
вступ України до Європейського Союзу.
Важливим також з економічної
точки зору є співробітництво
з Китаєм, адже Китай є також
країною економічним лідером у світі
i постачає значну
кількість продукції на ринки
всього світу та України зокрема.
І також важливим та цікавим
із стратегічної точки зору
є економічне співробітництво
України з Японією.
Так зокрема Японія надає значну
гуманітарну допомогу Україні
та є важливим партнером із подальшого
технологічного розвитку нашої держави.
А тепер пропоную дізнатися
більше про регіональне
політико-географічне положення України.
Нагадаю, що регіональне
політико-географічне положення -
це геопросторове
положення до системи країн
та політико-державних
структур певної частини світу.
Нагадаю, що Україна знаходиться
на Євразійському континенті
в такій частині світу, як Європа.
Отже, надзвичайно важливими
для України є зовнішньополітичні
відносини із країнами Європи.
Стратегічною метою України є
вступ до Європейського Союзу.
Також тепер перейдемо до
характеристики сусідського
політико-географічного
положення України.
Нагадаю, що сусідське
політико-географічне положення держави
зумовлює геопросторові
відносини з державами,
які межують із цією країною.
І, відповідно, виділяють
країни-сусіди першого порядку,
куди належать всі держави, які
безпосередньо межують з Україною,
а також виділяють
країни-сусіди другого порядку,
які межують із нашою
державою через кордони інших держав.
Вважається, що чим більше сусідів
має країна, то за інших рівних умов
її політико-географічне
положення є більш вигідним.
Чому це так? Зокрема тому, що це
надає країні альтернативного вибору
зовнішньополітичних та
економічних партнерів.
Продовжуємо далі
характеризувати сусідське
політико-географічне положення України.
На слайді ви бачите
протяжність кордонів України
із державами-сусідами першого порядку.
І, зокрема, одним із
геополітичних викликів для України
є велика протяжність
державного кордону з Росією,
адже на даний момент Україна
зазнає неоголошеної війни
та військової агресії з
боку Російської Федерації.
І таким чином ми з вами щойно з'ясували
- які є вигоди та загрози
на глобальному, регіональному
та сусідському рівнях
політико-географічного
положення України.
А тепер пропоную дізнатися більше
про адміністративно-територіальний
устрій нашої держави.
На момент проголошення
незалежності України,
сформований в Україні
ще за радянських часів,
адміністративно-територіальний
устрій мав наступний вигляд.
Він, зокрема, включав в себе
Автономну Республіку Крим,
яка була приєднана до України в
1954 році, також включав в себе
24 області, два міста
республіканського підпорядкування -
це міста Севастополь і Київ, також
605 районів, 435 міст, майже 10 тисяч
сільських рад і понад 1360
міських населених пунктів.
Перша спроба реформування
адміністративно-територіального
устрою України була
зроблена в 2005 році.
Втім, не була доведена до кінця.
І таким чином розпочалася реформа
децентралізації, яка, зокрема,
виділила три рівня в адміністративно-
територіальному поділі України.
До цих рівнів належать зокрема
- Автономна Республіка Крим,
області, міста Київ та Севастополь,
також райони та громади.
І відповідно до нового
адміністративно-територіального устрою
та реформи децентралізації
виділяється ще одна нова ланка
адміністративно-територіального
устрою -
це об'єднана територіальна громада.
Основною ідеєю реформи
децентралізації в Україні є передача
повноважень на місця і, відповідно,
стимулювання партисипативної
демократії та залучення населення,
тобто людей, що проживають
на цій території, до прийняття рішень.
Таким чином сьогодні ми з
вами дізналися багато нового
про те, як відбувалося
становлення української держави,
дізналися з вами про те, які
державні утворення існували
на території України в різні часи.
Також ми з вами охарактеризували
політико-географічне положення
України та дізналися більше про
адміністративно-територіальний устрій
України та реформу децентралізації.
А тепер пропоную перевірити
себе та відповісти на питання.
Питання та варіанти
відповідей ви бачите на екрані.
Будь ласка, дайте
відповіді на ці питання.
Правильні варіанти відповідей
я надам на наступному уроці.
І переходимо з вами
до домашнього завдання.
Пункти домашнього завдання
ви бачите на дошці.
Чекаю ваших розповідей
за хештегом на слайді.
Я вже чую як лунає дзвоник.
Отже, наш урок добігає кінця.
Дякую всім за увагу! До зустрічі!